aujourd'hui
pour une chaîne d'Internet qui s'appelle
thinkerview nous sommes en direct est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement s'il vous plaît ah oui
alors moi je suis essayiste j'ai écrit
plusieurs livres sur l'Union européenne
ou sur des sujets qui vont avec comme le
couple franco-allemand et je
collaborerai plusieurs médias un
Marianne Polony télé qui la chaîne de
télé web qui a fait fondée par Natacha
Polony de temps en temps un petit peu le
figarovox qui est le site de débat du
Figaro vous faisiez quoi avant tout ça
vous avez quelques cursus moi
je suis un produit de Sciences Po j'ai
fait un IEP à Grenoble et puis ensuite
j'ai passé des concours administratifs
et je me suis retrouvé dans une vie qui
n'a rien à voir avec ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'en fait
j'étais officielle dans l'armée pendant
[grognement]
j'ai
commencé aspirant et j'ai fini
commandant j'étais commissaire
des armées c'est aujourd'hui un service
interarmé mais ça l'était pas quand j'ai
intégré donc c'était dans l'armée de
terre et j'étais commissaire ça veut
dire c'est l'intendance l'intendance
administration les finances une partie
de la logistique c'est déjà parti en
OPEX quel
pays en Côte d'Ivoire en 2004 2005 j'en
ai fait sur 17 ans de carrière j'en ai
fait qu'une ce qui est relativement peu
et donc à la suite de l'armée vous avez
décidé de lancer un blog voilà c'est ça
voilà j'ai commencé à écrire en fait et
j'ai commencé à publier des papiers
d'abord
sur le blog ensuite un petit peu sur le
site de Marianne 2 à l'époque de c'était
Philippe Cohen qui qui dirigeait le site
de Marianne II et il avait recruté à peu
près tous les blogueurs qui qui
participaient à la défense de ses idées
et aussi sur coeur et puis maintenant je
suis revenue chez Marianne uniquement
voilà d'accord c'est quoi vos idées
dans quel domaine l'Union européenne par
exemple
moi j'ai écrit des livres critiques très
critiques voilà
c'est c'est un
truc de long terme parce que moi j'ai
quand j'avais 18 ans je me suis engagé
politiquement ça a été mon seul
engagement d'ailleurs au Mouvement des
citoyens de chevetement quand
il a quitté le PS il a fondé le
Mouvement des citoyens et voilà j'ai été
là pendant trois quatre ans puis ensuite
je suis rentrée dans l'armée et là le
militantisme est interdit
le PS vous en pensez quoi c'est c'est
des
des cadavres des cendres il reste
quelque chose non
il reste rien ils auront peut-être même
pas d'élus aux européennes moi j'ai
jamais été très fan du PS voilà
pour moi sont des gens qui ont fait
semblant d'être de gauche et qui ont qui
ont trahi toutes les idées de gauche au
nom de l'Europe justement
ah c'est difficile comme question
j'avoue qu'il y a des moments où je me
pose la question de savoir si je le suis
encore parce qu'il y a chez les gens de
gauche un espèce de espèce de
prédilection pour une forme de
terrorisme intellectuel où notamment
quand on a mes idées sur l'Europe on est
assez facilement fascisé
traité de nationalistes etc et donc
c'est vrai qu'à force je finis par me
demander si finalement le clivage gauche
droite a encore un sens mais en tout cas
moi mes idées de départ c'est celle de
la gauche républicaine c'est à dire une
gauche qui est pour juste
répartition des richesses pour que la
France reste un pays industrialisé pour
son indépendance vis-à-vis
des grandes puissances pour c'est à dire
par exemple pas dans le cadre de l'OTAN
pas dans le cadre de l'Union européenne
et [grognement]
puis tout un tas d'autres idées sur
l'école notamment donc je pense que
c'est ce qui permet aux
citoyens de
à l'enfant de devenir un site
progressivement un citoyen quoi c'est
pour moi la transmission c'est une façon
de s'émanciper individuellement et
j'aspire
à l'Évangile l'émancipation individuelle
des citoyens et à l'émancipation
collective via le social
l'Union européenne la dislocation
géopolitique mondiale est-ce que l'Union
européenne va tenir le choc
non le
problème de l'Union européenne c'est que
c'est un ensemble juridique et un grand
marché c'était une structure juridique
ou économique et c'est pas une puissance
quoi donc elle ne géostratégiquement
elle ne pèse pas tellement dans la
mondialisation et d'ailleurs on voit
bien que chaque pays a un peu son agenda
il y a des pays qui sont extrêmement
proches des États-Unis on a qu'ils le
sont moins voilà et puis surtout c'est
un ensemble la manière dont elle est
organisée fait diverger les différents
pays elle ne favorise pas leur
coopération mais elle les fait diverger
de manière structurelle c'est-à-dire que
on peut toujours dire on va voter tel ou
tel truc au Parlement européen mais en
fait ça changera rien parce que les
traités tels qu'ils sont font que ça
fonctionne une certaine manière et c'est
certaine manière de manière structurelle
favorise certains pays et ruine
l'économie d'un certain nombre d'autres
pays donc ça ça ne favorise pas du tout
la coopération entre les nations ça les
sépare
donc l'Allemagne les pins
les pig c'est les ah oui c'est ce qu'on
a oui bon ça se dit plus trop ça c'était
un acronyme qui
signifie Portugal Italie - Irlande
Italie - Irlande Espagne enfin c'était
les pays de l'Europe voilà la Grèce
c'était les pays d'Europe Méditerranée
en fait ce sont ceux qui ont le plus
pati du marché unique et de la monnaie
unique
parce que l'Allemagne les vampires
est-ce que oui
elle est vampiris elle les vampirisent
mais c'est lié aux structures de il y a
pas eu un grand projet allemand de
prédation du continent en fait il y a eu
un certain nombre de choix qui ont été
fait y compris par des dirigeants
français surtout
par des dirigeants français d'ailleurs
il y a eu le choix alors en 1986 nous
transformer le marché commun en marché
unique avec l'Acte unique qui était un
traité qui a dérégulé l'économie de du
continent quoi et qui a fait prévaloir
la libre circulation des capitaux et la
libre circulation des travailleurs là où
il n'existait avant dans le cadre du
marché commun que la lime circulation
des marchandises et ça a généré des des
phénomènes de polarisation qui ont
appauvri tous les pays périphériques et
qui ont considérablement enrichi
l'Allemagne
parce que les facteurs mobiles de
production c'est à dire le capital
travail sont allés se loger au cœur
industriel de l'Europe à ce qui était
déjà le cœur industriel de l'Europe
c'est-à-dire l'Allemagne et les pays
immédiatements voisins ensuite il y a eu
l'euro a
eu pour conséquence alors il faut savoir
que l'Allemagne au départ n'en voulait
pas tellement de l'euro la [grognement]
Bundes banque par exemple la banque
centrale allemande a été le fer de lance
de l'opposition à l'euro et c'est cool
qui a rapporté aux Allemands la monnaie
unique il a dit d'ailleurs dans une
interview au début des années 2000 dans
la presse britannique qu'il l'avait agi
comme un dictateur parce que le peuple
allemand n'aurait pas accepté s'il avait
soumis la monnaie unique à référendum
n'aurait pas accepté de ce départir de
sa souveraineté monétaire donc il y a eu
l'euro l'euro a été fait aux conditions
allemandes pourquoi justement parce que
les allemands n'en voulaient pas donc
ils ont dit nous on est d'accord on
prend
le on enfourche le cheval de l'euro
et vous nous foutez la paix sur tout ce
qui est réunification etc un processus
de réunification parce que le processus
de réunification a été très rapide très
brutale et colle vous voulez pouvoir
faire ça sans qu'on le mette des bâtons
dans les roues donc on a fait le
reconditions allemandes parce que
l'Allemagne est imposé sans quoi elle ne
participait pas ça fait que pendant des
années on a une politique monétaire de
type allemand la question que
la Windows Bank administré comme la
Bundes banque la banque centrale
européenne oui elle a été conçue sur le
modèle de la Bundes bond c'est-à-dire
une banque centrale indépendante et qui
par ailleurs est commission principale
de lutter contre l'inflation voilà parce
que pour tout un tas de raisons
historiques l'Allemagne est un pays qui
ne veut pas d'inflation européenne
imposée des directives à certains pays
c'est normal c'est son rôle c'est pas
son rôle son rôle c'est de faire
fonctionner le système bancaire européen
c'est à dire c'est c'est de refinancer
les les banques des États membres en
fait est-ce que la Banque centrale
européenne est devenue pas de banque
après la crise de 2008 toutes
les banques centrales ont émis
énormément de monnaie donc c'est
une banque qui est remplie d'actifs
pourrie d'activer et recouvrables bah
oui elle a dans ses coffres des titres
de dettes dans ce monde de pays qui sont
pas solvables donc notamment
la Grèce la Grèce un pays qui n'est pas
solvable
je
sais pas je peux pas vous dire les pays
l'Italie est un pays qui est très très
endetté et qui par ailleurs n'a pas
connu de croissance depuis qu'il est
entré dans l'euro c'est un pays qui
était un pays très industriel et qui
c'est beaucoup des industrialisé à la
faveur de son intégration dans le marché
unique et dans l'euro et je voudrais
terminer sur la monnaie unique parce que
je vous expliquais que on avait eu une
politique monétaire à l'allemande
pendant des années ça n'est plus le cas
la politique monétaire c'est beaucoup
passée puisque la Banque centrale
européenne pour sauver l'euro a dû
mettre en place des outils de politique
monétaire hétérodoxe notamment elle fait
du quantitative easing c'est à dire
qu'elle rachète des dettes des pays de
la zone euro alors que en principe dans
l'esprit des traités c'est non conforme
donc la politique monétaire n'est plus
une politique monétaire à l'allemande en
revanche l'euro reste surévalué pour
certains pays et sous-évalués pour
d'autres c'est à dire que le
taux de change de l'euro boost
la compétitivité de l'Allemagne
artificiellement parce que si
l'Allemagne avait gardé le marque il
serait plus fort et inversement il est
très surévalué pour d'autres pays alors
la France l'Espagne l'Italie le Portugal
la Grèce c'est les élections européennes
vous avez étudié les programmes des
différents partis sur l'aspect
économique est-ce que vous avez une idée
de ce qui est le plus viable le plus
réaliste le plus dans l'air du temps
est-ce que les parties européens du
moins les ceux qui se présente la
députation européenne sont réalistes
dans leurs objectifs parce que la
République en marche est réaliste est-ce
que la France est soumise était réaliste
aussi mais
parce que Macron a déjà raté en fait il
a échoué son projet europ bien c'était
de créer ce qu'on appelle une union de
transfert c'est à dire au sein de
laquelle il y ait un véritable budget
fédéral qui soit le pendant de cette
monnaie fédérale qui est l'euro pour
qu'elle soit viable et c'est à dire
qu'en fait il voulait que les pays les
plus riches transfèrent massivement de
l'argent vers les pays les plus pauvres
pour pour les faire à nouveau congé
puisqu'ils puisque les pays ont divergés
mais l'Allemagne a dit non d'ores et
déjà elle a dit non puis c'était c'était
très évident qu'elle allait dire non
elle a consenti une petite ligne
budgétaire pour pour les pays de l'euro
qui seraient intégrés au budget de
l'Union qui lui-même est très très
faible elle l'Allemagne a dit non et
donc propose
de marché aujourd'hui alors qu'il y a de
plus en plus de recettes ici mais alors
que la crise grecque est passée par là
alors que le brexit est passé par là un
surcroît d'intégration fédérale
franchement c'est complètement
irréaliste c'est
bien l'Europe pourtant non
ben non pourquoi ce serait bien on a vu
ce que ça produit ça a produit la crise
grecque par exemple ça produit la
désindustrialisation d'un certain nombre
de pays ça a ranimé des vieilles
animosités quand vous voyez ce qui s'est
passé en Grèce en 2015 avec les Grecs
qui manifestaient avec des pancartes de
Merkel grimés en Hitler de son côté de
leur côté les Allemands les une des
presse allemande sur la Grèce était
injurieuse enfin ça ça a vraiment ça a
généré énormément de conflits pour ça on
dit l'Europe c'est la paix mais c'est
pas vrai du tout
le Portugal est en train de retrouver de
la croissance n'a
pas suivi les directives européennes
d'austérité l'austérité la troïka
c'était bien c'était pas bien c'était
fait
à la Grèce était atroce je l'ai suivi
moi pendant 6 mois au
jour le jour quoi j'ai vu comment ça
s'était passé ce qui a été fait au grec
c'est atroce c'est à dire que c'est un
pays qui est ruiné ils ont été obligé de
vendre tous leurs équipements publics
c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont plus aucune
souveraineté il ne possède plus leur
propre équipements ils ont vendu leur
port leurs aéroports ils ont vendu l'eau
l'électricité le gaz ils ont diminué les
salaires ils ont diminué les retraites
les gens aujourd'hui moi j'ai un ami qui
vit en Grèce et qui nous explique en
fait que les gens vendent leur voiture
et puis finissent par vendre leur maison
pour retourner dans les îles cultiver un
jardin quoi c'est ça les gens ne se
soignent plus le
taux de dépression à monter le taux de
suicide à monter c'est ça la réalité de
de la Grèce et les gens aujourd'hui qui
disent la crise grecque derrière nous
mais c'est carrément effarant le coup
humain de ce truc là est vraiment
insupportable et encore aujourd'hui
un peu amélioré les contes de la Grèce
pour qu'elle puisse rentrer non
sax
non ouais c'est ça ils ont un peu
maquillé les comptes mais les contes de
l'Italie aussi ont été maquillés mais de
toute façon comment dire même si ça
avait pas été fait la Grèce ne peut pas
supporter d'être dans le marché unique
et dans l'euro donc même si elle avait
eu des comptes nickel à ce moment-là
elle aurait fini un jour ou l'autre par
exploser économiquement par par devenir
surendettée par par être obligé de
baisser les salaires mais tous les tous
les pays l'ont fait mais c'est les
salaires il y a eu des réformes du
marché du travail partout vous parlez du
Portugal tout à l'heure le Portugal est
un pays qui s'y connaît aujourd'hui un
petit regain de croissance c'est parce
que il est descendu très bas au moment
de la crise et il a réformé quelque
chose comme dix fois son marché du
travail pour le flexibiliser comme on
dit pour libérer le travail comme on dit
Flexi libéralisation
ça nous emmène nous cette petite
histoire est-ce que on va finir par voir
l'Allemagne sortie est-ce qu'on va voir
la l'Italie sortie est-ce qu'on va avoir
un frexit le frexit ça résonne dans vos
oreilles ça vous parle pas tellement pas
tellement j'avoue parce que la France a
de grandes responsabilités dans ce qui
est actuellement c'est à dire le marché
unique c'est Jacques Delors l'euro s'est
Mitterrand vous voyez et puis c'est
l'autre c'est l'autre puissance du
continent enfin pour peu qu'elle le
veuille avec l'Allemagne donc moi cette
idée de frexit je le vois un peu comme
une désertion c'est à dire que moi je
veux pas sortir de l'Union européenne je
veux qu'elle disparaisse en tant que tel
c'est à dire que les traités tel qu'ils
sont soient dénoncés et enfin je pense
que la meilleure façon d'aller à
l'explosion c'est de mettre la pression
sur les pays du Nord parce que
l'Allemagne
a est un pays qui a des tropismes
particuliers mais il y a autour d'elle
tout un ensemble d'autres pays qui
fonctionne un peu pareil qui ont les
mêmes traditions économiques et moi je
serais pour qu'on leur mette une
pression d'enfer comment
de la manière dont les pays se entre
dans des rapports de force par la
diplomatie mais
il faut savoir que l'Allemagne est un
pays qui souffre de salaire
très bas et d'un sous-investissement
chronique c'est à dire qu'elle
n'entretient plus ses équipements
publics parce qu'ils ont une truc qui
consiste à vouloir absolument que leur
budget soit à l'équilibre parfait c'est
à dire point pas un poil de déficit et
ils sont dans un processus de
désendettement du coup il se
désendettent alors qu'ils empruntent
gratuitement sur les marchés et qu'ils
n'ont aucune nécessité de se désendetter
parce que quand on emprunte gratuitement
c'est bête en fait de se désendetter
et ce problème cette obsession de
l'équilibre budgétaire fait qu'il
n'entretiennent pas leurs équipements
publics alors les routes les ponts les
autoroutes les écoles etc etc donc tout
ça ça hypothèque l'avenir du pays mais
la pression sur l'Allemagne comment
notamment pour qu'elle relance sa
consommation interne ses investissements
et qu'elle augmente ses salaires
ce que les salaires c'est une société
c'est un salariat de vitesse en
Allemagne il y a des salariés bien payés
bien protégés et puis il y a tout un tas
notamment depuis les lois arts de 2005
c'est le chancelier garage Schröder qui
a qui a fait passer ses lois et elles
ont beaucoup déréglementé le marché du
travail et elles ont introduit tout un
tas de trucs genre auto-entrepreneur les
temps partiels à non plus finir les gens
qui sont obligés de cumuler des petits
boulots etc ça il y en a beaucoup et et
dans un pays aussi riche c'est quand
même préoccupant et puis il y a le
rattrapage entre l'Est et l'Ouest qui ne
s'est pas achevée encore les salaires
sont beaucoup plus bas dans
l'ex Allemagne de l'Est qu'ils ne le
sont à l'ouest donc l'Allemagne est un
pays qui aurait besoin d'augmenter ces
salaires et son investissement public
donc c'est pour qu'elle fasse ça qu'il
faut lui mettre la pression dans un
premier temps après ça nous offrirait un
sursis c'est-à-dire que moi je crois
qu'un jour ou l'autre peut-être même non
pas très longtemps l'Union européenne va
s'effondrer sur elle-même
mais comment vous dire s'échapper
en laissant les autres planter là alors
que tout le monde aurait besoin qu'on
augmente à nouveau les salaires qu'on
augmente à nouveau l'investissement
public qu'on s'affranchise la règle des
3% de déficit public qu'on gère l'euro
différemment et on aurait avec nous
l'Espagne Italie le Portugal la Grèce et
en fait tous les pays de l'Europe
méditerranéenne on va pas les laisser
planter là il faut il faut se mettre
ensemble pour mettre une pression
d'enfer aux autres et probablement
aboutir une fine à ce que ce soit les
autres qui partent parce que l'Allemagne
est devenu un pays d'abord
très conservateur et ça tient au
vieillissement de sa population
et puis de plus en plus souverainiste et
si on leur mette
souverainiste et ça s'accompagne chez
eux c'est assez particulier ce sont les
plus orthodoxes dans le domaine de
l'économie qui sont le plus
souverainistes parce que pour eux
voilà c'est surtout que l'Allemagne est
un pays créancier et les plus orthodoxes
économiquesment n'ont qu'une peur c'est
que leur pays en vienne être contraints
de payer pour les autres c'est-à-dire de
faire des transferts budgétaires massifs
de se prendre le défaut souverain de la
Grèce dans la figure et donc ils sont
devenus souverainissent par
orthodoxie en fait et aussi parce qu'il
vieillissent une population très âgée
donc eux ne veulent pas payer pour les
autres et ils ne veulent pas que les
autres mènent des politiques qu'il
considèrent eux comme laxiste donc si on
leur met la pression il n'est pas
impossible que ce soit eux qui finissent
par décider qu'on arrête de jouer
là c'est autre chose est-ce que
l'intrication du système bancaire
européen n'est
pas tellement profond que c'est
impossible de maintenir éclater l'Union
européenne sans avoir un effet domino
derrière quand on dit on a sauvé la
Grèce est-ce
que c'était pas pour sauver la Société
Générale la Bundes banque qui était
aussi impliqué dans l'adoptions
françaises et allemandes qui étaient qui
étaient qui étaient remplis de titres de
dettes grecques donc oui effectivement
il
y a eu une coupe je me rappelle plus de
quel montant mais il y a eu quand même
une coupe dans dans le stock de dettes
grecque mais elle n'était pas sûr c'est
ça qui est-ce qui s'est fait rembourser
en tête seniors je sais pas je sais pas
ça
mais en tout état de cause il y a une
coupe mais insuffisante et puis trop
tard trop tard parce que c'est voilà la
graisse est partie dans son tourbillon
et effectivement si c'est cette
intervenu trop tard c'est aussi parce
que la France et l'Allemagne ont voulu
laisser le temps à la Banque centrale
européenne de récupérer ce qui était
dans leur banque à elle elles ont sauvé
elles ont sacrifié la Grèce pour sauver
leur banque ceci dit ne pas sauver les
banques c'est
je veux dire on peut pas ne pas sauver
les grandes bandes les grandes les
grandes banques simplement une fois
qu'elles ont reçu de l'argent public on
nationalise
sur
la tête ou avec le flingue pas sur la
tête j'ai
pas réfléchi dans quel ordre mais ouais
pas avant après je sais pas je sais pas
ça vous parle
pas
la France aux
élections européennes Emmanuel
Macron ça
représente quoi c'est la France dans
l'Union européenne pour les députés
européens c'est 10% des députés
européens c'est ça je
sais plus mais en tout état de cause ça
c'est pas une importance des mesurer
dans la mesure où le Parlement européen
n'a pas de pouvoir en fait très peu de
pouvoir
l'enjeu là de ces élections c'est
d'abord de Macron
terminent en plus mauvaise posture
possible et c'est aussi que ce sera
amusant que la grande coalition c'est à
dire le PPE et le groupe
social-démocrate au Parlement européen
qui sont depuis toujours en coalition ce
sera amusant qu'il n'arrive qu'il
n'arrive pas à former une coalition ce
sa participerait à la bordélisation du
truc
le traité d'Aix-la-Chapelle ça vous
parle l'assemblée
l'Assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande ça vous
parle oui oui alors le traité
d'Aix-la-Chapelle c'est un drôle de truc
c'est
un traité bilatéral qui a été signé en
janvier dernier et on sait pas pourquoi
un
traité bilatéral franco-allemand on sait
pas pourquoi on signe un traité
bilatéral avec l'Allemagne maintenant
alors que il y a 28 membres encore dans
l'Union européenne pourquoi envoyer ce
message qu'il y aurait des pays
européens de seconde zone pourquoi
pourquoi pas avec l'Italie pourquoi pas
avec la Grande-Bretagne pourquoi mais
c'est le tropisme des élites françaises
ça allait les nous avons des classes
dirigeantes qui sont amoureuses de
l'Allemagne amoureuse de l'Allemagne
c'est et qui vénère le modèle allemand
qui adorerait pouvoir appliquer au
peuple français les recettes
qu'appliquent
l'Allemagne à ces salariés c'est-à-dire
des salaires très bas c'est à dire
l'austérité budgétaire on a des dir qui
adorerait pouvoir faire ça en France
nous [gémissement]
nos
politiques se présentent encore à
l'élection est-ce que ça va réellement
changer quelque chose à ce qu'on peut
changer l'Europe de l'intérieur
je crois qu'on peut adoucir
mais on peut pas la modifier en
profondeur on peut adoucir c'est-à-dire
que il pourrait y avoir une augmentation
de la consommation intérieure notamment
chez les pays dans les pays du Nord il
pourrait y avoir une relance des
investissements ça pourrait adoucir mais
je crois pas qu'on puisse la modifier il
y a forcément un moment où ça va craquer
ce que je vous dis tout à l'heure c'est
que si on va à la confrontation avec
l'Allemagne il n'est pas impossible que
ce soit elle qui décide d'arrêter les
frais voilà c'est pour ça que je trouve
intéressant de de leur mettre la
pression
on leur met la pression comment je vous
répète la question on leur disant on
vous
somme d'augmenter vos dépenses
intérieures d'augmenter les
investissements d'augmenter les salaires
s'ils veulent pas s'ils
veulent pas il faut à ce moment-là
effectivement il faut commencer alors
c'est compliqué parce que il faut violer
les règles à un moment c'est à dire que
un gouvernement qui qui arriverait avec
un projet très social serait obligé de
violer un certain nombre de règles mais
ce qui est compliqué c'est que
par exemple si vous avez un gouvernement
de gauche un peu radical qui arrive au
pouvoir et qui veut voter des lois qui
vont contre les
les règles européennes il faut savoir
que s'il y a litige parce que le droit
communautaire prime sur les droits
nationaux et s'il y a litige et s'il y a
quelqu'un enfin si l'une des
juridictions nationales en vient à
devoir se prononcer ils
vont dire c'est contraire à l'état de
droit parce que d'abord dans les années
60 la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne a procédé à ce qu'on appelle
la constitutionnalisation des traités
européens c'est à dire que elle a émis
des jurisprudences elle a acté que elle
a fait sortir si vous voulez le droit
européen de la famille de du droit
international et elle l'a transformée
elle a transformé les traités en quasi
constitution c'est à dire que elle a
opéré juridiquement par la jurisprudence
sans aucun contrôle démocratique une
sorte de saut fédéral
et à partir de ce moment là il
a été décidé par par la Cour de justice
que les citoyens pouvaient saisir
directement la
juridiction européenne c'est à dire que
le droit contrairement droit
international le droit communautaire ne
s'applique plus au seul état mais il
sait il s'applique directement aux
personnes et autre chose qu'elle a
décidé le
droit communautaire prime sur les droits
nationaux ça c'est ce qu'a décidé la
Cour de justice de l'Union et personne
n'en a fait grand cas parce que sans
doute la portée de la chose n'a pas été
analysé immédiatement c'était dans les
années 60 ensuite les juridictions
françaises ont décidé pour la Cour de
cassation en 75 et pour le Conseil
d'État en 89 qu'elle faisait l'heure ses
principes c'est à dire que désormais
quand elles ont à juger de quelque chose
elles font primer le droit communautaire
sur le droit national et en plus de ça
tout ça maintenant est dans la
Constitution européenne puisqu'il y a
été ajoutée au moment de Maastricht un
titre de la Constitution qui est à
l'Union européenne c'est à dire que
l'ensemble juridique européen était mis
dans la Constitution si vous voulez donc
on aurait effectivement un problème si
on voulait commencer à violer les règles
européennes ce serait un problème de
sortie de l'État de droit en fait il
faudrait modifier la Constitution quand
vous expliquer l'augmentation des
nationalistes dans les pays européens
ce qu'on appelle les populistes
comme vous voulez je crois que il
y a plusieurs il y a plusieurs raisons
il y a la crise économique
le chômage c'est
dû à la mondialisation néolibérale telle
qu'elle existe et qui est l'union
européenne c'est une c'est une petite
mondialisation pure et parfaite à
l'échelle continentale en plus de ça
directement branché sur la grande c'est
à dire que tous les accès de la finance
mondiale etc on est sûr avec la libre
circulation des capitaux de se les
prendre dans la figure donc c'est une
petite mondialisation parfaitement
achevée à l'échelle continental branché
sur la grande voilà et donc ça ça
favorise tout un tas de régression des
droits sociaux une
baisse des salaires des retraites la
destruction des services publics etc etc
la
crise financière elle a commencé comment
celle de 2008 c'est
largement aussi alors c'est une crise de
l'euro en fait
crise mondiale c'est une crise c'est à
cause de l'euro ça
a commencé aux États-Unis on l'a importé
à la faveur de la libre circulation des
capitaux parce qu'il faut savoir que
lorsque il a été décidé via l'Acte
unique que les capitaux circuleraient
librement dans les pays de l'Union et là
aussi décider qu'il circuleraient
librement vis-à-vis des pays tiers donc
en quelque sorte l'Union européenne a
servi de courroie de transmission à la
crise des subprimes et vous
avez un certain nombre de pays dans
lesquels ça s'est traduit par une crise
de la dette mais qui est aussi largement
liée au fait que ces pays se sont
surendettés parce que ils ont bénéficié
artificiellement de taux d'intérêt très
bas c'est à dire que les marchés leur
ont prêté dans les mêmes conditions que
ce qu'il prête à l'Allemagne et les pays
voyant que l'endettement ne coûtait plus
rien parce que les marchés jugeaient que
en cas de crise les autres pays de
l'Union se porteraient au secours des
pays en crise quoi donc ils ont côté un
peu légèrement à tout un tas de pays à
des taux d'intérêt qui correspondaient
pas à leur réalité économique donc un
certain nombre de pays ce sont
surendettés comme par exemple la Grèce
puis vous avez aussi d'autres cas de
figure dans le cadre de l'Espagne par
exemple ça a été une crise de
l'endettement privée une crise de
l'endettement immobilier la prochaine
crise ou la voyez des parties d'où
j'en ai aucune idée je
n'en ai aucune idée je pense qu'elle va
arriver
je pense que la BCE qui a sauvé une
première fois l'euro en 2012 a fait tout
ce qu'elle pouvait et que maintenant
elle arrive au bout de ce qu'elle peut
faire et qu'il est pas sûr du tout que
l'euro est survive à la prochaine crise
alors je sais pas ça peut être tout et
n'importe quoi il peut y avoir en Europe
on a beaucoup de banques qui sont
fragiles alors
notamment les banques italiennes et un
certain nombre de banques allemandes
parce que l'Allemagne a un gros volume
d'épargne
et si vous voulez l'épargne allemande
l'excédent allemande c'est aussi
l'endettement des autres c'est un jeu de
vase communicant si vous voulez
l'Allemagne
et a beaucoup d'argent et ça correspond
à l'endettement des pays périphériques
donc
cette épargne est placé sur les marchés
financiers pour une large part puisque
l'Allemagne est un pays qui refuse
d'investir et de faire des dépenses
publiques et tout ça participe à
l'économie casino et vous avez des
banques en Allemagne qui sont très
fragiles comme par exemple la Deutsche
Bank qui a eu plein de démêlés avec la
justice etc et ça c'est une banque
fragile voilà
systémique c'est une banque systémique
ceci dit si la logements que venait à
tomber je vois pas ce que pourrait faire
d'autre l'État allemand que de se porter
à son secours donc à ce moment là ce
serait l'Allemagne qui violerait les
règles l'endettement
de la banque c'est quoi
c'est pas trop c'est très compliqué
l'économie financière j'ai pas trop
c'est d'épargne
qui investit dans des produits dérivés
et compagnie le volume des produits que
la Dodge Bank a engagé sa représente
combien de fois le PIB de l'Union
européenne peut
sauver la Bundes banque la Dodge Bank
pardon
sera obligé de lui injecter des fonds
publics c'est ça sauver les banques en
fait c'est on
injecte des fonds on emprunte l'état
emprunte sur les marchés pour injecter
des fonds dans les banques c'est à dire
que on socialise en socialise les pertes
ce ne sont pas les banques qui
encaissent les pertes liées au fait
qu'elles ont joué à l'économie casino ce
sont les états et on les profits les
profits restent à
ceux qui les ont fait mais les pertes
sont socialisées c'est à dire que c'est
l'ensemble de la société qui qui éponge
qui éponge tout ça quoi la France elle
est dans quel état
français
l'endettement de l'endettement de la
France c'est combien de combien de
points de PIB c'est
100% maintenant elle
s'élève la dette publique c'est près de
100%
mais tout le monde en fait grand cas
alors que il y a pas forcément je
vais pas vous dire que il faut pas se
préoccuper de la dette mais actuellement
la France emprunte à des taux très très
bas et aujourd'hui on entend même
certains économistes très mainstream
j'ai entendu par exemple Philippe agion
qui a soutenu Macron le dire récemment
je crois que c'était sur France Inter
que la banque la France empreinte
désormais très très bas et qu'il n'était
donc pas nécessaire de s'obséder pour le
désendettement parce que comment
quand on emprunte gratuitement il n'y a
pas véritablement de besoin de se
désendetter on emprunte ces neutres ce
que ce que ce que l'État paie
véritablement ce sont les intérêts de la
dette les intérêts de la dette sont
quasi nuls si on emprunte gratuitement
les intérêts de la dette en ce moment
pour la France c'est combien
je passais énorme c'est beaucoup
parce que la dette c'est des impôts
futurs
les
services publics c'est des impôts futurs
aussi parce que la dette c'est des
impôts futurs la dette c'est la
contrepartie d'un excès de départ en
fait il y a trop de d'épargne
actuellement en Europe et il y a trop
d'épargne qui n'est pas investi en fait
quand vous avez des taux d'intérêts qui
sont si faibles en fait c'est un c'est
un signal qu'il faut investir et qu'il
faut consommer c'est quoi la stagnation
je sais pas trop je connais
c'est quand je pense que c'est ce que ça
doit être quand il y a une croissance
nulle et malgré tout de l'inflation je
suppose c'est pas tout à fait ça la
privée des questions pièges non pas
encore la privatisation on va on va vous
donner un bol d'air frais la
privatisation des aéroports de Paris de
l'aéroport Toulouse la privatisation des
barrages hydrauliques la privatisation
de la Française des jeux ça
rapporte quelques milliards c'est bien
c'est pas bien c'est complètement idiot
parce que en réalité enfin
moi j'ai lancé
avec l'économie de David qui est là une
pétition contre la privatisation d'ADP
parce que d'abord on trouvait ça très
grave c'est une grande une grande
entreprise française florissante c'est
la principale frontière du pays il y a
100 millions de plus de 100 millions de
personnes qui transitent par l'achat
année
c'est une entreprise qui est en
expansion il
me semble que son chiffre d'affaires en
2017 ça devait être quelque chose comme
plus 20% quelque chose comme ça donc
pourquoi elle est privatisée cette
entreprise qui marche alors
que pratiquement tous les aéroports dans
le monde sont publics
tous les aéroports américains sont
publics pourquoi aller privatiser
des entreprises comme ça qui rapportent
de l'argent à l'état alors qu'on
n'arrête pas les
trois ensemble NJ celles qui sont
contenues dans la loi pacte les trois
privatisations engie la Française des
jeux et aéroport de Paris ça doit être 7
ou 800 millions et aéroport de Paris
tout seul ça doit être 100 ou 200 je
pense
100 ou 200 millions qui qui viennent
dans les poches de l'état et qui ont
vocation a augmenté puisque c'est une
entreprise en pleine croissance donc
pourquoi elle est privatisée cette
entreprise pour alors les trois
privatisations mises ensemble engie FDJ
et ADP l'État en attente 15 milliards il
y en a 10 milliards qui vont être mis
dans
un fond pour l'innovation bon ça va être
placé sur les marchés c'est à dire que
ça va être soumis aux aléas des marchés
et il y en a 5 milliards qui vont servir
au désendettement mais encore une fois
le désendettement actuellement c'est pas
vraiment la priorité
c'est quoi la priorité et puis c'est de
maintenir les services publics et puis
comment je sais pas si vous avez fait de
la compta mais vous voyez un bilan
commencé vous avez vous
avez à droite le passif et à gauche
lactif la dette c'est le passif et au
regard de ce passif il y a tout l'actif
et tout l'actif c'est le patrimoine
public dont a des paix et les normes
fonciers qui va avec est-ce qu'on vend
les bijoux de famille parce qu'on a on
est en train de mordre la poussière là
est-ce que l'économie française est
tellement exemples que on est obligé de
vendre les bijoux de famille maintenant
ou est-ce que c'est le casse du siècle
c'est le casse du siècle clairement
c'est à la fois Macron
Macron flat son électorat et renvoie des
ascenseurs et en même temps il est le
macronisme c'est vraiment l'idéologie
des années 90 quoi c'est Juppé c'est
rien d'autre que Juppé on a lui on a
Élie Juppé en fait voilà que c'est pas
du tout alors ces gens se présentent
comme hyper moderne machin tout ça mais
ils sont complètement
[grognement]
oui c'est complètement idéologique cette
volonté de privatiser à tour de bras et
comme on a tellement privatisé qui reste
plus grand chose on va privatiser
l'aéroport de Paris qui marche en plus
les
actionnaires c'est un truc complètement
fou on va il va y avoir une concession
de 70 ans en fait et comme il y a des
actionnaires minoritaires aujourd'hui et
comme le patrimoine va devoir revenir
dans le giron de l'État dans 70 ans on
les indemnise parce qu'ils perdent le
bénéfice soi-disant de l'éternité alors
que en 70 ans ils ont ils ont le temps
de se retirer 10 fois les actionnaires
minoritaires donc ça veut dire qu'ils
vont être indemnisés on va les
indemniser pour pouvoir privatiser on
les paye pour privatiser on les paye
pour nous prêter de l'argent en fait
est-ce que c'est un emprunt déguisé
ah non c'est c'est on les indemnise
parce que dans 70 ans et ils vont perdre
une
partie de leur investissement voilà
ce qui était pas sûr du tout parce que
considéré comme un prêt
c'est ma question est mal formulée
est-ce que on privatise pour 15
milliards maintenant parce qu'on a
besoin de 15 milliards sinon on va
passer l'arme à gauche et on va pas
passer l'arme à gauche on a le on a tout
l'actif on a le patrimoine on a les
normes patrimoine fonciers de d'Aéroport
de Paris qui est gigantesque voilà c'est
ce que je vous dis l'actif d'un côté le
passif de l'autre il faut voir les
choses dans leur ensemble l'État
français n'est pas en faillite
voilà c'est sûr que l'État français
n'est pas en faillite il y a des pays
qui sont beaucoup plus endettés que ça
il faut ce qu'on parle au dernier de la
classe
non mais c'est un dogme cette histoire
de dette la dette l'Union européenne
l'euro est-ce que c'est ça a été élevé
au rang de religion complètement
ah oui oui vraiment
je sais pas c'est la dernière grande
idéologie voilà après après la fin des
idées l'idéologie de la fin des
idéologies c'est à dire que et notamment
à gauche c'est c'est terminé la
gauche la gauche à abandonnée la lutte
des classes et elle s'est elle en
accouche c'est bien vague la gauche
la gauche qui exercent le
pouvoir c'est à dire principalement les
socialistes mais avec des alliés c'est
leur idéologie de substitution ils ont
renoncé ils ont renoncé à la justice
sociale ils ont renoncé à
l'immensipation individuelle et
collective et ils ont ils ont mis en
place ce grand dessin qui est l'Union
européenne et c'était le grand dessin de
Mitterrand c'était c'était vraiment ce
qu'il voulait laisser dans l'histoire
comment on fait pour arriver à
convaincre les citoyens et citoyennes
que l'Europe est un piège comme vous le
pensez et c'est une question Internet et
comment sortir de cette religion
ce qui croit c'est très difficile de
leur faire changer d'avis on a beau
répéter que ce qu'il faut je pense
répéter c'est que l'Union européenne
n'est pas l'Europe l'Europe c'est un
ensemble de pays qui ne cesseront pas
d'avoir à la fin de l'Union européenne
qui ne cesseront pas d'avoir des
relations entre eux la Grande-Bretagne
va sortir de l'Union on ne cessera pas
d'avoir des relations bilatérales avec
la Grande-Bretagne c'est c'est pas à
l'ordre du jour et ce qu'il faut dire
aux gens je pense c'est que vraiment
c'est pas la même chose les différents
pays vont pas disparaître et c'est ou
alors on nous donne l'alternative c'est
soit l'Union européenne soit être isolée
c'est pas vrai du tout avant l'union
européenne n'était pas isolée la France
a toujours eu des relations
diplomatiques à droite à gauche donc ce
qu'il faut faire comprendre aux gens
c'est que l'Union européenne c'est une
façon contingente d'organiser le
continent européen par l'économie et par
le droit avec endroit
qui est supranational et qui dont la
production échappe pour une large part
au contrôle des citoyens par exemple la
jurisprudence de la Cour de justice de
l'Union échappe complètement au regard
des citoyens c'est de la jurisprudence
c'est la jurisprudence d'une cour
fédérale qui n'est pas adossée à un État
fédéral donc
c'est un ensemble juridique
supranational avec tout ce que ça
comporte d'atteinte
à la démocratie et
c'est un grand marché néolibéral c'est à
dire organisé selon les principes selon
les quatre libertés alors les
circulations du capital du travail la
libre prestation de service et la libre
circulation des marchandises
et elle est arc-boutée sur le principe
de la libre concurrence c'est-à-dire que
elle fait primer la concurrence au nom
de ça elle interdit par exemple les
aides d'État aux entreprises voilà
voilà l'UPR [raclement de gorge]
François azzino il a raison il a pas
raison
il a raison sur un certain nombre
d'analyses son analyse par exemple du
traité d'Aix-la-Chapelle était très très
bonne
oui d'accord
non il a fait une vidéo d'une heure où
il a mais il est il est très juriste en
fait il a analysé les articles un par un
et c'était vraiment très très bon vous
avez voté quoi là
je pense je suis pas sûr d'aller voter
voilà je suis pas sûr d'aller voter
en 2014 j'ai pas voté je suis davantage
tenté d'aller voter cette fois-ci parce
que dans
une optique un peu tout sauf Macron quoi
peut-être pour la France insoumise je
sais pas j'ai voté Mélenchon en 2017
le Luxembourg on en fait quoi l'évasion
fiscale on en fait quoi vous avez des
préconisations vous avez des des idées
autour de ces sujets là je vous pose des
questions volontairement vague pour vous
me posez des questions d'économistes et
je suis pas économiste
donc ce qu'il faut être économiste pour
critiquer l'Union européenne
non moi je me suis lancée dans dans ça
parce que c'est un sujet
pluridisciplinaire on fait de l'économie
on fait du droit on fait de l'histoire
c'est c'est vraiment ce qui c'est la
raison pour laquelle je me suis pu on
s'intéresse à plein de pays voilà c'est
je connaissais pas spécialement
l'Allemagne quand j'ai commencé à
travailler sur l'Union européenne or on
ne peut pas ne pas s'intéresser à
l'Allemagne quand on travaille sur
l'Union européenne et du coup j'ai lu
énormément de choses sur l'Allemagne et
c'est très intéressant d'ailleurs parce
que c'est c'est un pays qui est
radicalement différent de la France
c'est le c'est un peu le négatif
photographique quoi dans dans la façon
d'asser construite en tant que nation
dans sa tradition politique etc et quand
on s'intéresse à ce pays on comprend
d'autant mieux ce qu'est la France et la
spécificité de la France
vous êtes déjà été vous avez déjà été en
Allemagne une fois pour
la fête de la bière
la
Chine qui commence à mettre ses doigts
dans l'Europe vous êtes intéressé un peu
à la Chine
oui bah j'ai vu que elle avait beaucoup
d'intérêt pour les pays d'Europe
centrale par exemple ils ont ils ont
monté un forum groupe qui s'appelle le
groupe 16+1 je crois et je me demande
même si c'est pas 17 + 1 aujourd'hui
qui réunit les un certain nombre de pays
d'Europe centrale et des Balkans et la
Chine pour discuter ensemble de tout ce
qui est nouvelle route de la soie etc et
ça ça fait partie des raisons qui
angoissent les Allemands c'est pour ça
que je pense que l'Allemagne est dans un
dans un mouvement qui va vers plus de
souverainisme parce que c'est un pays
qui rencontre malgré sa force apparente
qui a vraiment qui a devant elle
énormément de difficultés et qui va
devoir se recentrer sur elle-même pour
les régler en fait et la question des
pays d'Europe centrale c'est l'une des
questions
tout simplement parce que les pays
d'Europe centrale sont la base arrière
industrielle de l'Allemagne c'est à dire
que alors d'abord le patronat allemand
oui
vous voulez que je bois
le patronalement se sert des pays
d'Europe centrale et orientale ou les
salaires sont plus faibles pour faire
pour faire pression à la baisse sur les
salaires chez lui
et la deuxième chose c'est que
les industriels allemands réalisent des
délocalisations de proximité dans les
pays d'Europe centrale il fabrique en
Europe centrale et orientale des
sous-ensemble pour leur industrie qu'il
réimporte ils assemble ils mettent le
tampon made in Germany ils ont bénéficié
des coûts salariaux très faibles des
pays d'Europe centrale et ils peuvent
vendre ça ils ont bénéficié aussi du
fait que ces pays n'ont pas un droit
social très élevé qui n'ont pas l'euro
qu'ils ont un système fiscal qui est
plus avantageux et à partir de là ça
leur permet vraiment de faire du dumping
social en fait c'est ça et donc ces pays
sont complètement imbriqués aujourd'hui
dans le hub industriel allemand
et l'Allemagne voit dans assez mauvais
œil que la Chine est des ambitions dans
ce coin du monde
vous avez étudié un peu les flux
migratoires en Europe
un peu
j'ai étudié la crise des migrants
là encore on a vu que ça fonctionnait
pas
on a vu que ça fonctionnait pas parce
que
assez rapidement tout le monde n'en a
fait qu'à sa tête et en fait je pense
que simplement cette crise elle a révélé
que les pays les pays d'Europe parce
qu'ils ont divergé parce que le la
manière dont organiser l'Union
européenne les met en concurrence les
rangs inapte à coopérer c'est à dire ils
n'arrivent pas à coopérer pour faire
face à l'imprévu
de
déstabilisation alors un train européen
en termes d'économie et que il se
prépare à fermer hermétiquement leur
pays contre les afflux massifs de
migrants provenant du Portugal de France
et d'Italie ils
anticipent pas quand il y a les émeutes
de la fin en Égypte à
cause du prix du pain l'armée vous a été
à l'armée il y a pas de cellules de
prospective à l'armée ah mais moi j'ai
pas fait de prospective j'ai fait de
l'administration d'accord mais oui
connaissez les autres services vous avez
des copains dans l'armée qui j'en ai
plus tant que ça oui
évidemment il va y en avoir de plus en
plus des migrations les migrations
climatiques etc mais ça marche pas le la
coopération en matière de protection des
frontières l'Union européenne c'est la
protection des frontières c'est une
question c'est l'Europe telle qu'elle
est empêche l'Europe telle qu'elle
devrait être de ce contre et ben ça
devrait être alors il y a eu des il y a
eu des options qui ont été mises sur la
table dans les années 60 c'est à dire
que vous aviez si vous voulez l'Europe
supranationale des pères fondateurs avec
l'ambition de créer quelque chose de
proto fédéral et l'ambition de le créer
par le marché
et en face de en phase de Jean Monnet
Robert Schuman et compagnie il y avait
les gaullistes
eux voulaient créer une Europe qui soit
une entité géostratégique qui existe et
qui soit indépendante du reste du monde
et ils ont pour cela et élaborer le
plancher les deux plans fouchés qui
étaient des plantes de pour bâtir une
robe des nations en mettant en accent
prioritairement le travail commun sur la
défense et les affaires étrangères c'est
à dire que la coopération ce serait
faite prioritairement dans les domaines
du régalien sur le mode de la
coopération gouvernementale et non sur
le mode supranational c'est-à-dire en
préservant les souverainetés nationales
bon ce sont les supranationalistes qui
l'ont emporté et ils ont fait un marché
un marché qui fait diverger les
différents pays et qui les mettent en
concurrence les uns avec les autres
fiscales sociales et bien les crise des
migrants aurait nécessité une réponse
qui est du domaine du régalien
éminemment politique l'Europe telle
qu'elle est rend impossible ça elle a
pas été faite pour ça l'Union européenne
c'est un marché sans frontières
d'ailleurs sans frontières ça fait
partie des présupposés
c'est à dire plus de frontières on
abolie les frontières et d'ailleurs
l'Union européenne n'a pas de frontière
elle s'élargit sans cesse
est-ce que excusez-moi [soupir]
je reprends mes notes donc j'aimerais
qu'on recrute quand même l'Assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande
c'est bien c'est pas bien
de quoi ils vont discuter mais déjà le
Parlement européen sert pas à grand
chose alors une assemblée parlementaire
c'est le traité de la chapelle qui est
intéressant à regarder
les extrêmes droites en Europe c'est
dangereux
les extrêmes droits en Europe
c'est
l'expression d'un désir de
réappropriation et de réhabilitation de
la nation
et mais alors
ça se passe pas partout de la même façon
c'est très identitaire dans les pays de
l'Est vous connaissez les pays de l'Est
j'ai lu j'ai lu pas mal de choses sur
eux
sont des pays qui ont été très longtemps
privés de leur souveraineté et qui ont
l'habitude en fait d'un régime de
souveraineté limité qui s'accommode tant
bien que mal de l'Union européenne qui
sont des bons élèves économiquement de
l'Union européenne mais qui sont
traversés par des problématiques
identitaires qui sont liées au
fait que c'est ce sont là encore des
populations qui vieillissent énormément
ils ont un double problème de faible
natalité et de d'émigration il y a
beaucoup d'immigrations dans tous les
pays d'Europe de l'Ouest c'est comme ça
que certains pays d'Europe de l'Ouest se
transforment en pompe aspirante de la
main d'oeuvre des pays de l'Est et cette
dépopulation en fait les met dans une
dans un état d'esprit de c'est un
politiste bulgare qui dit ça crastef
s'appelle qui explique que l'IA dans son
pays et dans ce d'à côté une sorte de
peur de la disparition ethnique et c'est
ça en fait qui génère
les politiques très favorables à la
natalité en Hongrie par exemple où on
explique aux femmes qu'il faut qu'elle
fasse des enfants etc et très
défavorable à l'arrivée
de population aux mœurs étrangères c'est
un effet corrélatif du à la fois de la
souveraineté et d'un de la dépopulation
CD pays vraiment qui leur population
s'effondre gravement
ça a été poussé par Emmanuel Macron
c'est une bonne chose c'est pas une
bonne chose qu'on se rapproche comme ça
de l'Allemagne qu'on qu'on laisse une
partie de notre siège à l'Allemagne
c'est
pas écrit qu'on va leur laisser une
partie de notre siège c'est écrit que
nous allons tout faire pour aboutir à ce
que l'Allemagne soit elle aussi dans le
club des membres permanents on en fait
une priorité de notre diplomatie alors
que Ben comment dire il y a déjà deux
pays d'Europe de l'Ouest en tant
que membre permanent de conseil de
sécurité c'est la Grande-Bretagne et la
France
et la priorité c'est certainement pas de
rajouter l'Allemagne quoi donc mais il a
été écrit noir sur blanc que c'est
devenu l'une des priorités des deux pays
que de favoriser l'accession de
l'Allemagne et
en fait ce qu'on voit dans ce traité
alors déjà on se demande pourquoi un
traité bilatéral pourquoi alors que il y
a des tas d'autres pays en Europe
pourquoi pas eux déjà le message envoyé
est un peu gênant
et puis surtout le contenu du traité est
très inéquitable en fait très
inéquitable parce que la France donne
mais
en commun un certain nombre des choses
dont elles dispose c'est à dire que elle
va œuvrer elle va elle va mettre au
profit de l'Allemagne son réseau
diplomatique il
est question que dans le domaine de la
défense les pays se rapprochent beaucoup
il est question qu'il travaille ensemble
pour les exportations d'armement il est
question que il se porte assistance
mutuelle en cas d'agression et on se
demande bien pourquoi voir marquer ça
dans un traité alors que concrètement
c'est déjà le cas pour tous les pays qui
sont membres de l'OTAN et
donc c'est un traité qui va assez loin
dans les domaines où la France est
leader c'est-à-dire diplomatie défense
et qui ne contient rien de plus dans
les domaines économiques
dans le domaine économique c'est là que
l'Allemagne pourrait mettre des choses
en commun parce que ben c'est elle qui a
les excédents elle a des excédents
faramineux mais le traité ne contient
rien de neuf par rapport à ce qui existe
déjà dans le cadre de l'Union européenne
pas de rebond pas de modification du
mandat de la BCE pas de transfert
budgétaire et puis de toute façon je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure Macron a essayé
d'obtenir la mise en place d'un budget
fédéral de la zone euro il a échoué donc
statu quo sur les questions économiques
et des avancées dans les domaines où la
France a quelque chose à offrir c'est ça
concrètement c'est on veut bien vous
prendre ce que vous avez mais on ne vous
donnera pas ce que nous avons voilà
voilà le message que qu'on doit recevoir
comme tel quoi c'est le message envoyé
dans ce traité
un petit mot sur elle j'aime bien
Nathalie l'oiseau elle a un petit jeu
qui est sorti là il faut jouer à son jeu
un petit jeu où
elle est en Mario Bros là mais
celui-là est très bon parce que un
moment il y a il y a Mélenchon qui
apparaît et puis c'est l'ogre russe
voilà
donc le message envoyé en fait pour pour
ce sont les mêmes qui nous tannent en
nous disant que Ben l'Europe c'est la
paix l'Europe c'est la paix l'Europe
c'est la paix et qui nous explique qu'en
fait ce serait quand même bien si
l'Europe pouvait
devenir un pouvait
pouvez se confronter à la Russie quand
même à la Russie puis à tous les autres
parce que c'est ce qu'on nous explique
on nous dit l'Europe c'est pour être
fort par rapport aux États-Unis par
rapport à la Chine par rapport à la
Russie donc voilà l'Europe c'est la paix
mais c'est aussi l'adversaire du monde
entier
ok connaissez
fiscal combat c'est un jeu qui a été
créé par la France insoumise
à la fin de notre interview est-ce que
vous avez un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
c'est dommage qu'on n'est pas parlé des
gilets jaunes on a tout le temps
qu'est-ce que vous voulez me demander
sur les gilet jaune
parce que c'est le canari dans la mine
de la mondialisation prédatrice
comment dire ça ça exprimé
un désir de réappropriation il y a eu il
y a eu deux types de revendiquées de
grande revendications en fait il y a eu
les revendications économiques et
sociales justice fiscale les services
publics etc et il y a eu la thématique
du RIC qui
très probablement est
une lointaine conséquence du référendum
de 2005 et d'une sorte de frustration
référendaire en fait parce que en 2005
la France a voté non au traité
constitutionnel européen les Pays-Bas
aussi et en 2008 on leur a on nous a
fourni le traité de Lisbonne donc les
gens ont compris en fait qui n'étaient
plus souverains et la thématique du
rythme les
gilets jaunes ça représente combien de
personnes je me fais l'avocat du diable
ils ont été largement soutenus dans
l'opinion ils ont été largement soutenus
dans l'opinion
c'est une blague internet non mais ce
qui est très intéressant dans ce
mouvement
de réappropriation là et de désir de
récupération de la souveraineté on
leur donnera pas le RIC mais je vous dis
juste que ça exprime ça exprime un désir
de réappropriation et c'est à dire un
désir de souveraineté populaire c'est la
question de la souveraineté qui se joue
là et
les gilets jaunes c'est aussi un
symptôme d'un autre phénomène qui est
celui de la de la sécession des élites
en fait c'est la réponse à la sécession
des élites
pour plein de raisons parce que
comment les il
n'y a pas que les élites la sécession
des élites c'est la était analysée bon
elle a été analysée dans les années 90
par un sociologue américain qui
s'appelait Christopher lâche qui a écrit
un livre sur la sécession des élites et
les dommages que ça pouvait causer en
termes de démocratie et elle
a été ré-analysée aujourd'hui par des
gens comme Emmanuel Todd ou des gens
comme Jérôme Fourquet et en fait ce
qu'on voit c'est que cette sécession des
élites elle est vraie dans le domaine
économique et social c'est-à-dire que
les plus fortunés ne veulent ne se
sentent plus solidaires du reste de la
population et font ces sessions sur le
prend le plan financier c'est à dire
l'évasion
fiscale c'est ça en fait c'est un refus
de la solidarité nationale
et il y a la question aussi qui moi me
semble intéressante et que dont je
voulais du coup vous parler c'est la
question de la fracture éducative et
c'est ce que dit Todd dans son dernier
ou avant dernier livre je crois c'est
que auparavant
on a eu toute la phase de monter
en puissance de l'éducation primaire et
de l'éducation secondaire et une forme
de d'homogénisation de gens qui avaient
bénéficié des deux ce qui a nourri un
inconscient un imaginaire égalitaire en
fait ce qu'il explique et qui s'est
passé ensuite c'est que le
l'enseignement supérieur ne
s'est pas généralisée mais qu'en
revanche ceux qui ont des diplômes
supérieurs sont désormais suffisamment
nombreux pour ne pouvoir parler qu'à
leur père en fait et cela nourrit un
inconscient inégalitaire avec des gens
qui sont
et le haut de la société quoi qui est en
boucle sur lui-même si vous voulez et
qu'il n'a plus qui ne se reconnaît plus
de devoirs de solidarité vis-à-vis du
reste de la population et l'Union
européenne exprime bien ça aussi c'est
l'ensemble institutionnel que les
classes dirigeantes ont fabriqué pour
pouvoir
pour pouvoir échapper
à leur responsabilité c'est à dire que
les dirigeants aujourd'hui sont élus
c'est à dire qu'ils bénéficient de
l'onction de légitimité que confère le
suffrage universel mais ce ne sont pas
eux qui conduisent les politiques
véritablement donc ils ne sont on ne
peut pas leur on ne peut pas demander
des comptes à ceux qui les conduisent
vraiment c'est à dire la BCE enfin
la banque la Cour de justice de l'Union
la
commission toutes
les responsabilités véritables échappent
à l'AC sanction des urnes et ça c'est
très important de le constater c'est que
c'est pas une fatalité c'est une union
l'Union européenne ça a été fait pour
disloquer les nations parce que la
nation est le cadre à l'intérieur duquel
le bas peut demander des comptes
assez représentants et à partir du
moment où on a fabriqué cet ensemble
supranational où sont conduites les
vrais politiques économiques notamment
mais pas seulement les citoyens ne
peuvent plus demander des comptes on a
décorrélé le suffrage et la décision et
ça c'est important de le savoir
on
se fait une petite révolution est-ce
qu'on est-ce qu'on redevient français et
qu'on bascule
la table et qu'on leur explique un peu
les choses est-ce que les gilets jaunes
l'ont fait protesté
gentiment qui sont fait énuclés dessus
vous avez vu la tête de Macron le 10
décembre il était liquide il était
liquide pourquoi parce que bon il y a
quelques blagues blocs qui sont un peu
énervées ils ont fait un petit
guet-apant à quelques gendarmes sous
l'Arc de Triomphe et qui avaient tous
les patrons du CAC 40 qui commençaient
nous faire une descente d'organes
c'était
quelques gilets jaunes un peu violents
qui ne représentait que 0,001%
du mouvement les gilets jaunes ils sont
très calmes très pacifiques qui
qu'est-ce qui voulait faire avec des
gilets jaunes je pense quand même qu'ils
ont été secoués parce que les Macron
démission etc c'est un phénomène bizarre
Hollande était relativement méprisé et
Macron a pris conscience qu'il était haï
en fait c'est très bizarre de voir cette
haine contre ce type parce qu'il
représente la sécession des élites en
fait tout simplement il en est la
substantifique moelle c'est un type qui
est c'est la trajectoire parf
comme principal partie d'opposition le
rassemblement national et ça met ces
gens en situation d'être sans cesse
reconduit en fait c'est dramatique
on fait quoi
bah on fait quoi on fait quoi on
conscientise les gens on leur explique
comment ça fonctionne moi j'essaie
d'expliquer pourquoi on ne peut on ne
pourra pas aller vers la justice sociale
et qu'on ne pourra pas renouer
avec une démocratie qui fonctionne
normalement dans le cadre de l'Union
européenne c'est déjà pas si mal on sort
alors et puis on leur fait après on la
refait la même
je pense que ça se pose
pas dans ces termes
je pense qu'il faut avoir un programme
et dire
un projet de société quoi et dire quoi
qu'il arrive on l'appliquera
et la démonstration c'est
pas un peu de des incantations de faucon
on fait ça
quand on dit on sort c'est aussi
maintenant
c'est terminé les gars et hop
mon idée moi ce serait quand même de
faire sortir en premier quelqu'un
d'autre j'aimerais bien que ce soit les
Allemands
ou
les Italiens parce que eux ils sont
vraiment mauvaise posture mais les
Allemands aussi ils commencent à entrer
en récession ils vont pas tarder à
entrer en récession et les Italiens eux
économiquement
ils sont dans une situation dramatique
et puis démographiquement aussi ils font
plus d'enfants les Italiens
est-ce que vous avez des conseils de
lecture
combien vous en voulez on commence par 3
5 max
alors oui je
conseille en premier il est sorti cette
année le livre de Jérôme Fourquet
l'archipel français qui a un livre sur
l'éclatement de la société française en
différents archipels comme le titre
l'indique et il explique notamment le
phénomène de Sécession des élites mais
pas seulement il
explique aussi comment la
décristianisation et corrélativement la
disparition progressive du communisme à
fait éclater à fait monter un ça ça
produit de l'individualisme et comment
la société se disloque petit à petit à
la faveur d'un individualisme qui monte
et c'est très amusant il fait une étude
sur les prénoms et il montre que le
stock de prénom a considérablement
augmenté dans la
Kevin Jordan des
jeunes issus de l'immigration aussi qui
sont
donc ça c'est mon premier conseil
c'est ce qui me vient alors le dernier
bouquin de Toad aussi où en sommes-nous
j'ai
pas
dans quel domaine dans quel domaine de
spécialité vous avez pas l'habitude
qu'on vous prenne pas par la main pour
orienter vos réponses non
j'ai surtout pas réfléchi à la question
en fait vous lisez quoi en ce moment je
viens de terminer un roman qui a un
roman d'un ami en fait et je lis un
petit bouquin sur les services publics
ça s'appelle comment alors le roman
s'appelle leur guerre perdu c'est
mon ami David descouilles qu'il a écrit
et c'est un roman qui met en scène des
personnages qui militent chacun pour
le souverainisme mais dans des parties
différentes il y en a deux qui
commencent au PS et il y en a un qui
termine chez Chevènement il y en a un
qui termine carrément au Front National
et puis il y en a une qui commence chez
Seguin et qui termine bon elle passe par
chez NDA puis elle termine nulle part et
il explique comment tous ces gens qui se
sont d'abord opposés à Maastricht puis
au TCE en 2005 comment tous ces gens qui
ont voulu résister à l'intégration
européenne se sont fait balayer et
comment ils sont aujourd'hui les cocuses
de la vie politique en fait parce que
vous me demandez depuis tout à l'heure
que faire mais je ne sais pas pour qui
voter c'est c'est un gros problème vous
allez vous présenter en politique non
non
ce
serait bien que quelqu'un de nouveau
ramasse le drapeau et le brandissan
nouveau
celui de la République sociale en fait
ce qu'on ce à quoi aspirer à la fois la
gauche républicaine et une bonne partie
des gaullistes la République sociale
bon courage question
d'internet je prends les questions
d'Internet alors pourquoi les Allemands
sortiraient de lieu on a déjà expliqué
25 fois non est-ce
qu'il va y avoir une convergence entre
la crise énergétique crise économique et
explosion de l'Union européenne pour
Madame n'est pas énergéticienne madame
n'est pas économiste et madame à
quelques vues sur l'explosion de l'Union
européenne
est-ce qu'elle va exploser je le crois
quand je ne sais pas comment je ne sais
pas non plus
question internet si je vous dis 4 de
gauche c'est être contre l'ordre établi
et vous d'accord
contre l'ordre c'est pas être contre
l'ordre c'est être contre l'ordre actuel
oui
c'est être contre l'ordre tel qu'il est
c'est à dire violemment injuste en fait
violemment injuste inégalitaire mais
être contre l'ordre en général non je
crois pas ça
c'est bon est-ce que la technocratie
européenne s'oppose obligatoirement à la
démocratie européenne
oui je pense l'avoir expliqué les
technocrates en fait ce sont ceux qui
sont dans les structures indépendantes
comme la Cour de justice la Commission
et la BCE ce sont ceux qui exercent qui
conduisent véritablement les politiques
économiques et on leur a transféré cette
charge les élites nationales leur ont
transféré cette charge pour pouvoir
décorer les le suffrage et l'exercice
réel de la responsabilité une
question à mon avis qui vient de l'UPR
est-ce que le frexit c'est un bon moyen
de pression sur l'Allemagne
je pense pas qu'ils y croient des masses
les Allemands à ça
mais le frexit le truc c'est que est-ce
qu'on peut vraiment gagner une élection
sur ce terme sur ce terme en fait je
suis même pas sûr il
a pas gagné non
il a gagné mais c'est un peu c'est un
peu c'est un peu différent quand même la
Grande-Bretagne c'est un pays qui est
Retif à la manière dont toujours été
rétif à la à l'autoritarisme continental
en fait ça devient ça en fait le
continent européen ça devient de
l'autoritarisme inégalitaire à tout crin
et eux ben ils sont libéraux en fait
c'est pas c'est pas leur tradition que
se passe-t-il si on viole les règles de
l'Union européenne comme vous le dites
ça dépend lesquels mais je pense que
pour une part ça peut finir par à la
sanction financière non la sanction
financière on peut non la sanction
financière qui va nous forcer à payer
non le problème c'est le problème de
sortir de l'état de droit en fait
alors autre question est-ce que vous
êtes inquiète de la dérive policière de
l'État
honnêtement oui un peu et c'est pas mon
genre c'est pas mon genre moi j'ai porté
l'uniforme etc je suis pas du tout
hostile à la police en tant que tel mais
je pense que la manière dont elle est
utilisée en ce moment est un peu
inquiétante rassurez-vous
on a une bonne armée si commence à être
trop méchant à mon avis nos amis en kaki
vous leur expliquer que c'est pas comme
ça qu'on doit traiter ça population
c'est un vrai ça doit être un
déchirement pour certains policiers
parce que c'est des gens qui sont issus
des catégories populaires et c'est des
gens qui objectivement on les mêmes
intérêts que que immédiat que les gilets
jaunes donc pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux ça doit être très dur après
vous avez toujours quelques sadiques qui
aiment cogner ça ça existe
donc on arrive à la fin de notre
interview est-ce que vous avez un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
il faut lire des livres
il faut mettre un pull quand on a froid
conseil pour les jeunes générations je
sais pas que vous dire moi je pense
qu'il faut lire des livres ne pas ne pas
se laisser en boucané par le bruit
médiatique constant qui est en plus
favorisé par les chaînes d'infos en
continu les réseaux sociaux etc
l'actualité médiate enfin disserté
pendant des heures sur le fait que
Nathalie Loiseau a parlé de Blitzkrieg
en fait c'est pas très intéressant ça ça
endort tout ça ça des
images d'elles avec des têtes de bennyle
sur son compte Twitter il faut pas il
faut pas espionner mon compte twitter
juste
avant
elle ressemble à Benny Hills c'est comme
ça
pour faire ma vieille conne je serais
tenté de dire d'aller voter mais comme
je suis pas sûr d'y aller je vais
peut-être m'abstenir engagez-vous dans
l'armée oui alors ça pour le coup oui
moi je pense que c'est l'armée c'est un
milieu où l'ascension sociale est
possible en fait il
y a beaucoup de sous-officiers qui sont
qui ont été militaires durant et il y a
beaucoup d'officiers qui ont été
sous-officiers et ça a un milieu on le
sait peu mais plus
plus égalitaire en fait
l'ascension sociale est possible voilà
et tout le temps quand même
pas tout le temps mais il y a des
conditions il y a des concours etc etc
il y a des examens à passer
et puis sont des gens qui pour un
certain nombre évidemment pas tous il y
a toujours des exceptions mais qui sont
qui ont ils sont attachés à l'idée de
servir en fait et non pas au désir de se
servir ça c'est pas si c'est plus si
fréquent général servir l'intérêt
général c'est
ça une vraie élite normalement une vraie
élite c'est une élite qui se met au
service des
autres et qui rend la société ce que la
société lui a donné c'est à dire la
protection des biens la protection des
propriétés l'école gratuite les soins
gratuits etc tout ça c'est ce qu'on a
reçu
c'est c'est pas tout à fait anormal que
de vouloir le rendre de vouloir rendre
de vouloir de vouloir payer sa dette en
quelque sorte ce qui n'est pas tellement
normal c'est de ne pas vouloir le faire
c'est à dire de l'utiliser tout ce qui
est possible et imaginables en termes
d'exil fiscal pour ne plus contribuer
par exemple au financement des services
publics parce que quand on a beaucoup
d'argent il y a de tas de choses qu'on
peut payer sur des fonds privés les
écoles privées etc les soins en clinique
les gens passaient les meilleurs et moi
je trouve ça vraiment c'est très bizarre
comme façon de fonctionner de se dire je
ne dois rien qu'à mon talent et donc je
vais faire tout pour ma gueule et je ne
me sens pas solidaire de la société dans
laquelle j'ai grandi et de ce qu'elle
m'a donné ça c'est vraiment bizarre pour
moi
merci merci à vous
[musique]